Oh, hello, I'm firepower
. I'm a 19-year-old high school senior in Daegu, South Korea, and I'm running a channel on YouTube under the name
Darcy.  I don't know, but I'll take a picture
[Music]
Uh, Uh
[Music] Uh, there's a
4 W.  When the minute comes, 1 wakes up and gets on in
10 minutes. Put some makeup on.
Kotele is
still g30 waist, so it's a little
bit of a bit of a bit of a bit of a bit of a bit of a bit of a bit of a bit of a bit of a bit of a bit of a bit of a bit of a bit of a bit of a bit of a bit of a bit of a bit of a bit of a bit of a bit of a bit of a bit of a bit of a bit of a bit of a bit of a bit of a bit of a bit of a bit of a bit of a bit of a bit of a bit of a bit of a bit of a bit of a bit of a bit of a bit of a bit of a bit of a bit of a bit of a bit of a bit of a bit of a bit of a
bit of
Nucleus
[Music]
Look, we
only have one class per class. After
class, we take a 10-minute break, and there are 4 periods.
5 we are
2 tones.
I'm going to go to the presentation and enter the health room for about an hour. Parking
When I'm in the 3rd year of high school, all I do is
solve problems and take classes
.
In the 3rd grade, the module
class is matched with dance, so it really keeps giving me problems, so it's really boring to look at.
woo woo
I'll try it very once
.
There is not
4 I cut this at 10 o'clock and this is Lee
. I don't like the blood that is not available overseas or the rice that I want to introduce, so I make rice and
that's Samgyetang.
Do what you do Ah ah ah
benz If there's time to spread bullets, this is a person's second term.
Lee In-gi hyung, Isuzu,
our song city, sells bread, and the amount is
wide. ant king
co
oh oh oh oh
wm.
Let's take a place a Let's get rid of it Leem
[Music]
Burns ku ost once per server 2u Cream is delighted Scott
so Deng Pistol Eye star This time especially valve a woman the or
will Figure
peeling difference rez Cold sea chooses
woo woo
[Music]
x  Even if there is a tree of words after talent first, it
was part of the update of the evaluation.
Split Now, the writing is so good, I wonder if I forgot I miss it even when I solve it Where
i woo
3 hours Lalala 5,000 Today it’s not a common bile duct I don’t
fire a gun and immediately come up with fourteen lasagna
After dinner, again from 7pm to 11pm, there is a palm tree  But it
went out a bit well
Oh, it's rather our song
Come to the chime of 7 Come right away
You came to the viewer too and said something
First ah I'm hungry Second I need to plant some blood Third I want to die Fourth ah it's cold
Four tones There is no acupressure
Like this, the 3rd year of high school is the highest year and
they are about to take the exam  The college entrance exam is the college entrance exam
, so I mean to study hard right now, but I can
do
it.  September  When I wrote how to
ridicule home f la spray much to my day or fax between monthly muti
children's ng group's looking for oh old low tide 2 amen heartburn
quickly know now I can go out and say the truth
4 11 o'clock look back at divination time  It's like
this Until then, we're back again, what are we doing, and we need more members, but
we're mine, Nepa-kun.
There are friends who came to study at 1:00 and 4:00 in the morning as if they were going to self-study.
Try it If you are curious about more Korean
gangsters, can you come and visit me?